This is the Peter Pan Story,
roughly speaking is Peter Pan is this
magical boy.
Pan means Pan is the god of everything,
roughly speaking,
right?
And so it's not an accident that he has
the name Pan and he's the boy that won't
grow up and he's magical.
Well,
that's because children are magical.
They can be anything there,
nothing but potential,
and Peter Pan doesn't want to give that
up.
Why?
Well,
he's got some adults around them,
but the main adult is captain hook.
Well,
who the hell wants to grow up to be
Captain Hark?
First of all,
you've got a hook.
Second year a tyrant and third,
you're chased by the dragon of chaos
with a clock in its stomach,
right?
The crocodile.
It's already got a piece of you.
Well,
that's what happens when you get older.
Time has already got a piece of you and
eventually it's going to taste for you
and eventually it's going to eat you.
And so the hook is so traumatized by
that that he can't help but be a tyrant.
And then Peter Parent looks out
traumatized Herc and says,
well,
no,
I'm not sacrificing my childhood for
that.
So that's fine,
except he ends up,
can you lost Boyz in Neverland?
Well,
Neverland doesn't exist and who the hell
wants to be king of the lost boys.
And he also sacrifice is the possibility
that a hell of a real relationship with
a woman because that's Wendy Wright and
she's kind of conservative middle class
London dwelling girl.
She wants to grow up and have kids and
have a life.
She accepts her mortality.
She accepts her maturity.
Peter Pan as to contend himself with
tinkerbell.
She doesn't even exist.
She's like,
she's like the fairy of porn.
She doesn't exist.
She's the substitute for the real thing.
And so,
but the dichotomy that you're talking
about,
it's very tricky because there's a
sacrificial element in maturation,
right?
You have to sacrifice the pleura
potentiality of childhood for the
actuality of a frame.
And the question is,
well,
why would you do that?
Well,
one reason is it happens to you whether
you do it or not,
you can either choose your damn
limitation or you can let it take you
unaware when you're 30 or even worse
when you're 40 and then that is not a
happy day.
You see,
I see people like this and I think it's
more and more common in our culture
because people can put off matt maturity
without suffering and immediate penalty,
but all that happens is the penalty
accrues and then when it finally hits it
just wallops you because when you're 25
you can be an idiot.
It's no problem.
Even when you're out in a job search,
it's like,
well you don't have any experience in.
You're kind of clueless.
It's,
yeah,
you're young,
you know,
it's no problem.
We can.
That's what young people are like,
but they're full of potential.
Okay,
well now you're the same person at 30.
It's like people aren't so thrilled
about you at that point.
It's like,
what the hell have you been doing for
the last 10 years?
Well,
I'm just as clueless as I was when I was
22.
So.
Yeah.
But you're not 22,
you're an old infant,
right?
And that's an ugly thing and all the
incident.
So the the reason,
part of the reason you choose your damn
sacrifice because the sacrifice is
inevitable,
but at least you get to choose it.
And then there's something that's even
more complex than that in some sense is
that the problem with being a child is
that all you are is potential and it's
really low resolution.
You could be anything but you're not
anything.
So then you go and you do adopt an
apprenticeship,
roughly speaking,
and then you become at least you become
something.
And when you're something that makes the
world opened up to you again,
you know,
like if you're a really good plumber,
then you ended up being far more than a
plumber,
right?
You end up being a good employer.
Not,
not that plumbers are not putting
plumber stale and it's like more power
to plumbers.
They've saved more lives than doctors.
So hygiene,
right?
So you know,
if you're a really good plumber,
well then you have some employees,
you run a business,
you make,
you train some other people,
you enlarge their lives,
you're kind of a pillar of the
community,
you have your family,
it's you can once you pass through that
narrow training period which narrows you
and constricts you and develops you at
the same time,
then you can come out the other end with
a bunch of new possibility at help at
hand and young talked about that,
a thought that the proper part of the
proper path of development in the last
half of life was to rediscover that
child that you left behind as you were
apprenticing.
And so then you get to be something and
regain that potential at the same time.
Very,
very smart.
Well,
he was very,
very smart.
So that's very wise,
very wise thing to know.
So Yep.
Sacrifice.
We'll,
we'll talk more about that too.
You get to pick your damn sacrifice.
That's all.
You don't get to not make what your
sacrificial,
whether you want to be or not.
That's a good thing to know as well.
So even though it's rather rough thing
to figure out,
but other questions
I have no one else.
Okay.
That thing you just said about noticing
and more and more and people live into
their 20 [inaudible] yeah.
What do you think about that or anything
that comes from in terms of culture,
we live in,
think universities facilitate it because
you can go to university to not be
something instead of going to university
to be something and that's it's pleasure
island
and the price you pay for it,
especially in the U.
S is debt and you're enticed into it
because the administrators can pick your
pocket.
So they they rob your future self while
allowing you to pretend that you have an
identity.
Right?
Very,
and you can't declare bankruptcy with
your student loans.
In the US,
it's indentured servitude and it is
precisely pleasure island.
It's exactly that.
And so tuition fees have shot way out of
control and part of the reason that
universities don't make more demands on
their students and let them get away
with all the things they let them get
away with is because they're basically,
why the hell would you chase them out?
They're $100,000
or more so they can do whatever they
want as long as you get to sell them to
the salt mines.
Right.
Did you know it's not the only reason
because the other thing that's happened
is that the rate of technological
transformation is so fast now and the
rate of turnover of things is that it's.
It is genuinely harder for people who
are say 18 to 20.
When I was a kid,
roughly speaking,
the kind of rough patch for,
for,
for life was probably 14 to 17,
something like that.
Now it's,
I think it's 18 to 25,
something like that.
And I think the reason for that is that
all of the jobs that the bloody hippies
complained about being doomed to in the
19 sixties have now disappeared.
There.
Problem was,
oh my God,
I'm going to have to work for a
corporation and get a salary for the
rest of my life,
you know,
and then I'll just end up with a pension
and that'll be my whole life.
It's like,
well,
it seems like a lot better deal than an
endless round of part time starbucks
jobs.
So,
you know,
some of it is that it's,
it's just,
it's,
there's a space now in our culture that,
that is lacking for people to make that
transformation from,
from adolescence into adulthood.
And so it's just,
it's,
it's the cost of that is stalled.
It's not a good thing.